the TQ Samson bulk carrier leaves the
Ukrainian Port of Odessa carrying
rapeseed and corn in what could be the
last grain shipment from the port under
the current Black Sea grain initiative
the deal was first brokered by turkey
and the United Nations a year ago to
safely allow the export of Ukrainian
grain products during the war
particularly to poorer countries
although almost half has been shipped to
Rich Nations the grain deal was twice
extended by Russia this year but now
expires on Monday
Turkish president
erdogan says he hopes efforts with the
U.N will convince Russia to keep the
corridor open the Kremlin says President
Vladimir Putin is waiting on a
commitment to remove sanctions against
the export of Russian foods even though
Russian grain exports have risen sharply
since the 2022 invasion of Ukraine he
will use whatever is available to him
whether it is military political or
economic to extort to extort Ukraine to
extort the West
Inland on the front lines the battle's
rage as Ukraine makes slow gains in its
counter-offensive it is now
controversially received U.S cluster
Munitions banned by many countries
including Canada
in a newly released segment from an
interview with Russian State tv Putin
said Russia has plenty of its own
cluster Munitions
he claimed Russia has not used them yet
but will do so if Ukraine does their use
by both countries in the war has been
widely documented and not only have the
Russians used these cluster bombs
extensively but what is called the dud
rate that is the number of these that do
not explode is extraordinarily High by
Western standards left unexploded those
can injure civilians long after a war
footage from earlier in the invasion
shows the apparent use of cluster bombs
in civilian areas at attacked by Russia
Redmond Shannon Global News London